Süßigkeiten in knallbunten Farben - das schreit doch nach Chemie und ungesunden Farbstoffen.
Aber nichts da! Das geht auch natürlich.
Und zwar mit Farbstoff aus Algen. Wie die
Industrie das macht und wie man aus
grünen Algen plötzlich blauen Farbstoff
herauskitzelt, weiß Sebastian Lege.
Besonders bei Süßkram scheint: je bunter desto besser!
Doch synthetische Farbstoffe gelten als schädlich und stehen oft in der Kritik.
Die Lösung der Industrie wächst hier in
Sachsen-Anhalt und sie ist klein und grün.
Algen! Genauer gesagt Mikroalgen.
Jörg Ullmann ist der Herr über das Algenmeer.
ULLMANN: "Im Prinzip steht hier ein riesiges Aquarium,
nur dass wir das Aquarium nicht eckig gebaut haben sondern in Röhrenform."
In dem 500 Kilometer langen Röhrensystem wachsen die Algen vor sich hin.
Wichtig: Ganz viel Licht! Nur so bildet
sich genügend Chlorophyll, denn das ist
am Ende verantwortlich für die grüne
Farbe.
Nach der Ernte werden die Algen
getrocknet und zu Pulver gemahlen.
Und fertig ist der natürliche grüne
Farbstoff.
Aber die Alge kann mehr als Grün...
Sebastian Lege weiß wie!
LEGE: "Jetzt ist die Alge noch grün, aber gleich zaubere ich daraus strahlend blaue Farbe."
Dafür nimmt Sebastian Spirulina-Algen - aufgelöst in Wasser.
Um an den blauen Farbstoff zu kommen, muss er das grüne Chlorophyll loswerden.
Der Trick: filtern, filtern filtern - und warten.
Die Industrie hat Hochdruckpressen mit
extrem feinen Filtern.
Sebastian hat dafür eine große Spritze.
LEGE: "Die hat mir mein Kumpel aus dem Zoo geliehen.
Nämlich eine echte Elefantenspritze!"
Damit erzeugt Sebastian jetzt Druck und jagt die Algenflüssigkeit durch einen Mikrofilter.
Der filtert auch die letzten Chlorophyllpartikel raus.
Übrig bleibt....
LEGE: "Haha! Strahlend blaue Farbe! Ist das cool!"
Sebastian freut es - und die Industrie erst recht!
Aus den blauen und grünen Farbpigmenten
können durch verschiedenste Zusätze
ganz viele unterschiedliche Farben entstehen.
Also keine Chemie, keine
schädlichen Nebenwirkungen!
Zur Abwechslung mal ein ganz natürlicher
Trick der Lebensmittelindustrie.
Na geht doch!
Übrigens: Dr blaue Farbstoff aus
der Alge ist ein spezielles
Eiweißmolekül und heißt für Phycocyanin, falls ihr mal mit einem Fremdwort angeben wollt.
Noch mehr kunterbunte
Tricks, Checks und Duelle aus der Welt
der Lebensmittel findet ihr auf unserem
Kanal ZDFbesseresser!